in three locations around Berlin
billboards have popped up advertising
one-of-a-kind property developments
interested buyers are told to call this
number
I'm Doherty annoyed I'm a visual artist
and based in Berlin upon closer
inspection misspellings and wordplay
give the ruse away sharp mo refers to
the meat higher wealth investor
squeezing out every panel of the person
who needs to desperately rent an
apartment I mean there are horses
walking around there are different
animals so you can get an idea that
that's first not real but yeah it's also
a little bit funny for some at least
after the billboards went up
dorotea began receiving phone calls a
lot of phone calls I had American
numbers number from Hong Kong Sweden
Norway but the majority is definitely
from Germany and I think from Berlin
they just see ok a new housing
construction is here phone number and
they are interested in buying and that's
apparently enough to to give me a phone
call yeah I mean that says maybe more
about the actual situation in Berlin the
city is in the midst of a real estate
boom and dorotea's placement of her
billboards is intentional there in areas
for community spaces and art subcultures
have existed for decades I think there
are still differences between Berlin and
other metropolitan cities regarding
living quality regarding how the city
can or
but Berlin is constantly put in
comparison with those places as the
demand for housing continues to grow the
future of the very spaces Doroteo would
like to protect remains uncertain I see
all these advantages and all this
positive things are shrinking I mean
really going away so so so fast
but one thing her artwork has succeeded
in doing is turning up the volume on the
conversation I have a lot of interaction
with people I have a lot of discussions
going on everything I wanted to achieve
it the billboards yeah I think it
happened much more intense than I've
ever imagined it